words that we should use more of in our
life are words that give us the right
feeling we want to feel so I'll give an
example instead of saying now I work
super hard I do get tired and I do get
exhausted sometimes I'm very aware of it
and I'm cautious of it and I realized
that for a long time I just kept
repeating I'm tired I'm exhausted I'm
tired I'm exhausted and I'd say to my
wife and I still do it sometimes so it's
not that I'm perfect but you're making
me aware of it and I started to realize
that it didn't make me feel better by
saying it and actually what I was trying
to do was get a validation from someone
else to be like I know how hard you work
and you're amazing you're really doing
it for a reaction and then I started to
realize I am tired but why don't I just
say I'm gonna make some time to nap
today I need to find some time today to
rest I need to make sure that I get some
time to myself today like when you flip
it nobody just saying oh I feel amazing
because I don't feel amazing again you
don't want to lie to yourself but you're
trying to create words that help you
actually get what you need so me saying
I'm tired really what I need to be
saying is I need to get some more rest
today I better sleep early and when you
go buddy you know what I think I'm gonna
sleep early tonight that's perfect
because now I'll sleep early and I'll
get the rest and I won't be tired it
just creates this negative pattern of
complaining and whining and creating
that you know so what want to be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how you can brainwash
yourself for success
enjoy
rule number two manage your mind and
emotions with Tony Robbins what do you
think having said that what do you think
is the greatest human skill not habit
but mindset and skill that's a great
question I don't know if I got the what
the greater there's so many it depends
on what you want out of your life right
yeah but I think the ability to manage
your own mind and emotions is probably
one of the single most important and
maybe the second is the ability to
influence others because that's what
makes you a leader and hopefully you're
doing that for a higher good because
there are all kinds of leaders as you
know but I think I don't think most
people are very good at emotional
Fitness most people are just not as
happy as they could be and I did one
book money Master the game it's kind of
like this one only and what I did in
that case is I interviewed you know 50
of the smartest Financial people play
dalio Carl icon Warren Buffett and
out of 50 of them and you know again
it's in my judgment I can be completely
wrong and I spent a lot of time with
them some have become really good
friends there's probably four or five
that are really happy people oh money
makes people unhappy you know money it
has nothing to do with money money makes
you more of what you are just magnifies
if you're mean you have more to be mean
with if you're kind you have more to
give you know but I think that most
people are just they haven't learned to
manage what's going inside doesn't
matter how much abundance they have
they're still in apple we've all seen
people that great comedians that have
killed themselves uh Anthony Bourdain
beautiful man traveled the world killed
himself you know
um you know fashion designers that have
done it we've all seen all these
different people Kate Spade and it's
like what they had everything
except they didn't Master what's going
on here and here and you know this is
why you lived your life the way you have
us as well so I think that skill set is
the most important one that's why even
in the book my last two chapters I think
are the most important because it's
really about the power of the mind
because like everybody knows about
placebos right they're only discovered
in World War II and it was discovered by
accident this doctor ran out of morphine
and he's treating these these people
that are badly injured and you know you
need the morphine not just so they're
out of pain but so they don't go into
shock and the actual person who
discovered this gets no credit was a
nurse because the nurse had him a
syringe and said we've got some more
morphine so he believed it and he said
you'll be out of pain in just less than
a minute he injected them and in every
case none of them went into shock 90 of
them were out of pain and they used
nothing it was saline right so after
World War II he went back to Harvard and
he was the person that created what we
now considered being the double bind
studies which are always compared to a
placebo right and but most people don't
is the bigger the placebo intervention
the more powerful the Mind believes it
so a small pill is less effective than a
big pill an injection is more powerful
than a pill in terms of its
Effectiveness the most powerful is a is
a sham surgery
um the the Veterans Administration did a
study and they did on people doing knee
surgeries and they took one-third of the
people and they just cut them open and
mysticize them and so the backup did
nothing A year later this group the
group that had no surgery had the least
amount of pain the most amount of
flexibility most about it so they
stopped funding those surgeries give you
an idea but that's how powerful it is
and so when you it's even more than
Harvard did a study where they took
barbiturates
babies big red pills and said this is an
amphetamine you need to prepare your
body because you're going to speed up
eating him something fake they give him
an actual drug that slows the body down
and the body sped up so most people
don't understand the power of the mind
and so what I've tried to do is show
people even in this book here are the
things that you can do to take control
of your mind because if you take care of
your body and then you don't take care
of your mind and emotions you can be
miserable yeah okay yeah what spot that
question was something you said you said
that you start your morning by jumping
in the cold that's right and you never
feel like doing it and you said that I
just said to my buddy it's time to go
and that's why the question is I was
like that's a really interesting skill
that you've trained yourself to be okay
with discomfort yes you're training
yourself as your first skill of the day
is yes I am okay with uncomfortable
things yes and I know I can get through
this yes and that to me is what sounds
like a really important part of
emotional Fitness it is because unless
you can push through discomfort and
those things that are going to give you
the greatest reward require discomfort
initially yeah right and the discomfort
it's like you know my original teacher
Jim Rohn used to always say you know
there's two pains in life the pain of
discipline or the painter right you know
discipline weighs ounces regret waste
tons you know and so I've trained myself
to do that and then I meditate then I
always make an acknowledgment call
briefly or leave a voicemail for someone
just because to spark the day and then I
do the first thing I do is always
whatever is the most difficult yes
because then you have momentum for your
day and when you train your brain to do
what's difficult first
then emotional Fitness just comes
naturally and more importantly so does
achievement so does your ability
contribute to other people well number
three have a positive attitude with
Lewis house this is something I learned
in sports early on is to have a positive
attitude when things go bad now the
world is filled with a lot of different
negativity drama stress and sometimes
it's hard not to fall victim to joining
in on the negativity this is one of the
reasons why my father growing up would
not let us watch the news he would not
let us watch commercials that talked
about a lot of harmful things or the
news because he didn't want us to be
susceptible to hearing about things that
maybe are happening in a micro level
that are blown out of proportion that
seem like it's happening all over the
world but it's really only happening in
a small level he didn't want us to
emphasize on all this negative energy
this negative attitude so he eliminated
those thoughts from our mind to support
us in the positive in sports as well I
would also have coaches that you know
things wouldn't always go our way and I
used to be so negative I used to be so
reactive when I missed a shot when I
dropped the ball when I messed up when
something that I did was wrong or was a
mistake I used to beat myself up so much
or when we'd lose I was such a sore
loser I just have a bad negative
attitude and our coaches over the years
would really teach me like that isn't
helping you that isn't supporting you or
your teammates around you but having a
positive attitude when things go wrong
will lift your teammates up we'll lift
you up to help you improve for the next
play in the next moment it's really all
about having that positive attitude
because the negative doesn't usually
serve us for anything ever there are
times absolutely to speak up and be a
stand for when bad things are happening
to you or happening to other people or
around you but that's not what I'm
talking about I'm not talking about that
specific moment in time I'm talking
about spending hours of your day
thinking about yourself negatively and
thinking about the world negatively
around you just ruminating on how
negative everything is that prevents you
from showing up as the best version of
yourself and I believe you're robbing
yourself and your loved ones and the
world of your gifts and who you truly
are when you sit in that negative state
so when I begin to shift into having a
positive attitude it really helped me in
every area of my life and negative
things or things that I don't like
happen around me all the time but it's a
practice even today and when I'm hit
with these adversities or these
obstacles I try to ask myself how could
it possibly serve me in the future
or if it's worth putting so much energy
into it around a negative attitude is it
really worth it is it helping me in my
health is it helping me in my joy and my
love for others and my love for myself
by holding on to this negative energy
it's usually not worth the energy so why
do we do it so frequently you know
there's this book called don't sweat the
small stuff
because it's all small stuff you know
obviously there's adversity and there's
challenges but when you can have the
attitude around it it really shifts your
life and the people around you so you've
got to do the work to develop that
awareness to realize that for yourself
this isn't easiest took me a long time
and having a positive attitude is in my
opinion one of the most important things
to manifesting to attracting to feeling
better about yourself but one thing that
I've learned from the different guests
and the experts on the show in the last
few years is that what's most important
is getting to the root of what's causing
you to stress the pain the anxiety the
the negative feelings that you're having
because positive affirmations can only
get you so far if you're not also doing
the Deep work on what's really going on
what's underneath the trigger the
anxiety the fear Dr Caroline Leaf has
been on the show a couple of times I
really love her message and her
expertise and she said it's like putting
a Band-Aid on a bullet wound when you're
just trying to have positive affirmation
without actually going to the root cause
of what that trigger and negativity is
but if you're able to get to the roots
of some of the things causing you so
much pain and suffering and the negative
attitude that you have and then begin
working to stay positive and having an
abundance mindset that's when you can
really start to create real change and
start to see and notice the feelings of
positivity notice the feelings of
Happiness flood into your heart into
your body into your soul also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is develop an abundant
mindset with Joe dispenza how do we
change from having a scarcity mindset
into an abundance mindset especially if
the evidence is not showing that we have
abundance right now for some people
sure well look this is a tough question
to answer but I'll tell you that for me
um I'm going to see this
as a great opportunity brilliantly
disguised this as an impossible
situation that I'm not going to meet
this Challenge from the same level of
Consciousness I we have to go to a
greater level of awareness a greater
level Consciousness and create and
invent and figure out new ways to
connect and figure out new ways to
influence the Earth's field and create
new ways to change outcomes in reality
and it's not about one person doing it
it's the new Consciousness that must
emerge that isn't going to live in fear
because what we fear we give power to we
give our attention to that we don't live
as victims to our circumstances that we
create different circumstances that if
you face this present challenge as an
opportunity for a greater Consciousness
to emerge a a collective Consciousness
that sees behind the illusion of
Separation that could connect in a field
of in information and create one mind
create one heart and emerge like those
birds that all fly in one pattern fish
in one school you you get the appearance
that it's a bigger organism because
there's no leader in that flock there's
no leader in that school everybody's
leading it's everybody is demonstrating
it and and that's we have to step up
Beyond it and information is causing us
to see
that maybe maybe governments aren't
going to take care of us maybe the
churches are not going to take care of
us or synagogues or maybe you know a
medicine is not going to take care of us
and maybe all of those things that we've
relied on uh to change our inner state
uh it's not going to really we're not
going to really take care of that
certain point we got to take care of us
right right and appreciate it Dr Joe
preach it now we gotta we gotta face
this uh and there's no other alternative
yeah there there isn't another
alternative except waiting uh instead of
creating so so maybe it's a time in
history that you and I negotiated to be
here from some other space and time and
that we're here for an Awakening let's
just let's see what happens if we play
that out and you can't be afraid and you
can't be angry you can't be hostile you
can't be resentful and all of us is
consciousness that creates viruses that
create disease uh it's going to be a
different frequency we're going to see
it uh from a different level of Mind
rule number five Empower yourself with
Mel Robbins create habits of empowering
yourself because empowering yourself
forgiving yourself supporting yourself
as you move forward and do the work to
change your life that's how you break
the habit of victimizing yourself and
that's how you learn to do the opposite
which is supporting empowering cheering
celebrating yourself as you move forward
that's what's going to motivate you to
do the action and look if Chris and I
can go from having liens on this house
six years ago to literally building an
extraordinary business changing our
marriage to the point where we are
building our Dream House a house that's
so nice I can't even believe we are
going to live in this house because of
the hard work that we've done but I'll
tell you the singular habit that helped
us do it is we stopped victimizing
ourselves we stopped labeling ourselves
we started beating we stopped beating
the [ __ ] out of ourselves and we broke
that habit we changed the narrative by
learning how to empower ourselves rule
number six shift your negative mindset
with Tom bilyu does a negative mindset
have more effects on Mental Health in
the brain and does it get easier to
control your emotions if you try long
enough so first of all yes a negative
mindset is going to have an overall
impact on your mental health so anxiety
is the easiest one to talk about because
I've experienced it but I think
depression is also going to be hugely
affected by what you allow yourself to
repeat so one core mechanism of the
brain is to understand that while we are
a very active species it's meant to go
out and explore and master our
environment there's a secondary
evolutionary Force pushing on us which
is that we also want to conserve
calories to make sure that we survive
a famine so we have this dual competing
thing of wanting to go out and do cool
hence the Big Dreams and wanting to sit
on the couch and eat a bag of potato
chips hence why we procrastinate why we
feel lazy and the
way that the brain as a physiological
organ has dealt with this dual impulse
challenge over evolutionary time frames
is that it's a process called
myelination and what that does is it's
wrapping fatty tissue around neurons
that fire together at the same time
frequently so this is why they say
neurons that fire together wire together
they are literally getting optimized for
the efficient transmission of these
signals across those synaptic gaps and
the reason that they do this is that it
becomes easier from a caloric
perspective to do those things so now
you've made whatever you repeat whether
it's something empowering or
disempowering whether it's something
that makes you anxious or feel like you
can do anything it's going to make
thinking those thoughts and feeling
those feelings easier from a caloric
perspective it also begins to move it
into What's called the default mode
Network so the default mode network is
responsible for
anything that we'll call automatic
thinking if you've done something a
bazillion times you don't think about
brushing your teeth you just brush your
teeth you don't think about driving to
work oftentimes certainly before the
pandemic you just drive to work and
there were times where you would show up
at work and be like whoa I almost don't
remember the journey getting here and
the reason is that what ends up
happening is your cognition can be put
on to basically something else you're
thinking through daydreaming whatever
and the thing that you do in a
repetitive way is Just Happening
automatically super efficiently and it's
a thing that happens to the brain where
you can scan somebody and go up they're
in the default mode Network right now
and if worry anxiety Panic fear stress
if that's what you're doing all the time
then that's what's going to be moved
over made calorically easier to do moved
into the default mode Network so that by
default that's where you go and this is
where most people spend the majority of
their lives is living in that default
mode network of these emotions that
they've created these very well-worn
paths to looping around over and over to
feeling those feelings over and over and
so you can understand since the body
responds to your
the mental states that you're constantly
in that each of those mental States is
characterized by hormonal and
neurochemical states and the body will
have different long-term consequences
based on what you're feeling so for
instance if you are constantly stressed
or constantly anxious your cortisol
levels are extraordinarily High cortisol
levels begin to damage the um
the elasticity of your blood vessels is
one of the vectors of attack on your
body and so you don't want to stay in
these chronically elevated levels
because it deteriorates the Integrity of
the lining of your blood vessels and
this is the kind of thing that leads to
stroke or coronary heart disease so
being incredibly thoughtful not to loop
on those things which doesn't mean that
there aren't bad things going on in your
life but it does mean that when you
allow yourself to bloop that there is
this hormonal and chemical Cascade as a
response to that that your body will
have negative consequences to or
positive consequences if you're in a
loving calm State a lot and that's the
thing that becomes the default mode
Network that becomes the easiest thing
for you to think and you're in this
really calm and creative state a lot of
times then you're gonna prolong your
life
um so I I hesitate only to say that
because of course there are other
extenuating circumstances like if your
diet is terrible uh but you're in that
column and creative state a lot I think
you're still going to run into issues
and quite honestly if your diet is
messed up then the odds of you being
able to stay in that calm and creative
state are very very low because of the
communication that happens between your
brain and your guts getting into
dysbiosis is a whole nother thing but
anyway you want to be very careful the
things that you allow yourself to think
now how do you train yourself to get out
of that
get out of a negative default mode
Network and into a positive default mode
Network so one is something called
pattern interrupting this comes from
cognitive behavioral therapy it's
extraordinarily useful and I highly
encourage you guys to get very deaf to
this and this is simply not allowing
yourself to think certain thoughts and
every time you catch yourself doing it
to pattern interrupt and you remind
yourself you don't do that so for
instance one of the reasons that I don't
get overwhelmed is because I don't allow
myself to be overwhelmed that doesn't
mean that I can carry an infinite load
what it means is every time I can feel
that escalation I can feel like oh my
God this is overwhelming I say to myself
ah you don't do overwhelm and saying
that thought interrupts that pattern and
breaks me out of it brings my conscious
control back in right Victor Frankel
between stimulus and response there is a
gap we want to mind that Gap we want to
get in there insert something like this
statement I don't do overwhelm which
then puts me back into conscious control
and I decide what I want to insert in
terms of the emotion that I want to feel
which of course is more calm more
relaxed able to handle more things
now I also remind myself that doing less
is always an option so if there's just
too many things happening at once 99
times out of 100 even if I'm really in
something busy and there's a lot
happening if I feel overwhelmed coming
on Boom pattern interrupt I don't do
overwhelm and then I'm gonna sit down
I'm gonna deep breathe from my belly
and I'm going to slow things down
and I'm going to let that stuff go and
that's exactly how I'm actually able to
end up doing more because I don't let
that become a runaway process
I pattern interrupted I breathe from my
diaphragm I slow down it doesn't take
long to reset to get yourself focused
and then typically what I'll do at that
point is shift back into an aggressive
mental and emotional posture which then
helps me push through anything that
might potentially feel overwhelming
and that is the training so you're doing
that pattern interrupt you're doing the
physiological things that you need to do
to shift your state and then you're
inserting yourself back into that Gap
and you do that over and over and over
and over never wasting time being angry
with yourself that you start to feel
overwhelmed but instead being proud of
yourself that you do the pattern
interrupt that you slow things down
and when you reinforce that behavior
that's what begins to wire together and
now over time it becomes this very easy
Loop that happens automatically you
don't even think about it when you start
to feel that sense of overwhelm you
don't get lost in the overwhelm boom you
stop slow down breathe insert the
aggression in this case I'm just giving
an example from how I deal with it but
whatever you're going to do to deal with
it
I do something exactly uh similar to
that for anxiety I start to feel the
anxiety build up I'm not going to allow
that to become this runaway process I'm
going to slow down it happens again that
I'm going to breathe from my diaphragm
I'm going to relax I'm going to close my
eyes I'm going to start some sort of
visualization of things going well
instead of going wrong you only get
anxious when you imagine things going
wrong so now I'm going to force myself
to imagine them going well
I'm going to breathe from my diaphragm
doing the physiological work of making
sure I'm shifting State and just do that
over and over and over and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is avoid negative
people with Grant Cardone the thing is
not to just be positive not even to
offer this no negativity policy that I
talk about the way to avoid uh negative
and distracting people man is to vibrate
at a rate so fast okay that you're out
in front of them once I got a speeding
ticket actually here in Miami and the
police officer says why are you speeding
why are you in such a hurry I'm like
dude I'm trying to stay away from The
Crazies
okay if I can just get ahead of
everybody else I'm not distracted by
anybody but guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and stop
my mission see so I got my ticket and
moved on and went to the head of the
pack again see this is what I'm telling
you man look if you want to not be
bogged down by negative distracted
people you need to take responsibility
that you're slowing down enough to get
caught up by this magnetic charge of
distractive and negative people dude you
need to vibrate so fast that these
people are distracting other people not
you get way ahead of the crowd get so
busy that nobody's gonna jack with you
man because you're filling up your
pipeline you're full you're busy and you
don't have this stuff sticking to you
look if you got negative people around
you if you got distracted people and we
all do but if it's causing you to be
distracted and negative dude you need to
vibrate you need to fill up your
pipeline you need to explode blow up get
busy so this isn't happening to you
because you're partly responsible Plano
there is one practice
that if you can learn to consistently
Implement in your business
it'll change the entire direction it'll
it'll allow you to accomplish
crazy goals that you never thought were
possible and that is to make data-driven
decisions
it sounds super boring for any of the
heart lead passion driven type A
personality entrepreneurs out there
watching looking at data and looking at
numbers and look at spreadsheets might
be the most boring thing in the world
for you
but when the data is coming from your
customers the people consuming your
content the people who you're ultimately
selling to and you get insights into
them it can make a dramatic shift
in how you see your business how you
operate your company and how much money
you start to make I'm a big believer
that you make the big decisions in life
with the heart with the heart and the
small ones with the head big decisions
with the heart small ones with the head
the heart is why do you do what you do
why have you started this business why
is it so important to you what is the
mission you're trying to solve right so
for me I want to solve the world's
biggest problem I want people to believe
in themselves more that's the heart
there's no science attached to it it's
just hard it's just art the heart is Art
right it's creation and I love tapping
into that side
and then the small decisions with the
head in that
the things that I do have to work
otherwise I just have a hobby right if
you're only doing art and it has no
value to other people you're not talking
to customers you're not gauging
reactions you're not seeing how you can
get better then
you just have a hobby that doesn't pay
you right which can be fulfilling not
everything has to pay you but if the
goal is to have a business then yeah you
have to get paid otherwise you don't
have a company for very long
if you're only listening to the customer
data and you're only looking for
opportunities but you don't actually
like the thing then you're also going to
lose right because you're just chasing
domain but you're not curious enough
about you don't care enough about it you
don't have enough heart for it example
in my business if I were to make the top
10 stupidest things ex-person has ever
said that that data wise would blow up
because people would rather consume
negativity and poke fun at somebody and
try to tear somebody down than to learn
and try to improve their own life in
general it's so much easier to to laugh
and poke fun at somebody else and
criticize somebody else instead of
working on ourselves to become better
right entertainment versus education
entertainment is a lot easier to consume
than education because it requires more
work on your part
so I could do that and the data would
say hey go make these videos they will
do better but it doesn't match my heart
I don't want to do that
so the heart gets the veto power but you
have to still listen to the brain right
so big decisions with the heart small
ones with the brain
so let's bring it back to data-driven
decisions
a lot of people struggle with it because
they don't know how to make data-driven
decisions they don't know what numbers
to look at they don't know how to
collect the information they get quite
frankly bored of looking at the
information the data
and so then they make subjective
opinions
and often make the wrong ones yesterday
I'm on a call with a team of a somebody
super well known
huge presence you you know you would
know his name you've heard it inside out
I've profiled him millions of times you
know on my own channel
that kind of narrows it down but I can
tell you who
so I'm on the call with his team and
we're looking at some of his YouTube
videos and the goal is to reach even
more people on YouTube great so we
looked at one of the thumbnails and his
team said well he picked this thumbnail
like yeah but this thumbnail it's it's
just not going to work like this
thumbnail sucks I'm a best practice from
everything I've seen from doing 12 000
split tests on YouTube thumbnails like
this is
with a very high degree of certainty not
a good thumbnail in terms of getting
impact
getting more people to click on it
getting more people to view it and the
team said yeah but he picked that
thumbnail
I agree with you Evan I don't like it
either but he picked that thumbnail
okay well here's how you combat that
situation what is his ultimate goal his
ultimate goal is to have more impact his
ultimate goal is to reach more people
right probably let's you know make sure
we get that right you know if his if his
mom on her deathbed said you have to use
this as my thumbnail okay you know great
there's a there's a reason other than
business for picking that thumbnail but
if the goal of this video if we can
agree that the goal of this video is to
try to reach as many people as possible
to spread your message as wide as
possible yes perfect let me help you do
that the challenge becomes it's one
person's subjective opinion against
another's and the person who's in charge
is almost always going to win that fight
right if the person who's at the top
says I want this
and then somebody underneath says but I
think this would be better
and there's no data to support anything
it's just one subjective opinion against
another the person at the top usually
wins so I said okay here's what you do
you agree that the goal is to get as
many views as on the video as possible
in an ethical honest way we're not
clickbaiting we're not doing something
against the brand
let's split test it
so here's what you want to do here's an
idea that I've got let's split test it
for two weeks and see what happens
and what I've always found is that
people will listen to the data when they
feel like
you're on the same page when they feel
like you're fighting for the same goal
as them because if you can then show him
that hey this video this is the case
that you bring
this video
if I change the thumbnail did twice as
bad twice as good right it does twice as
the two x's twice better whatever
doubles the impact right if you could
bring by changing to the thumbnail same
video by changing the thumbnail
you can get twice as many views here's
the data to show you not just my
subjective opinion but here's the data
to show you here's yours here's what it
did here's the one that we tried for two
weeks so let me try for two weeks here's
what we tried for two weeks
double the views
double the impact
what do you prefer you tell me what's
more important do you still want to go
with that because it again you have to
have some other reason for it and and
this isn't said in a condescending way
it's like hey help me understand this
thumbnail that we tried
double the performance which one do you
want to go with and they always go with
the one that gets better results the
challenge is when you're bringing the
idea
it's just your opinion
and they will almost always trust their
opinion over your opinion until you come
with the data honestly I think we're all
thinking small
you're thinking small I'm thinking small
we're all thinking small compared to
what what we're capable of and I think
we've been conditioned to think small
we've been conditioned by our upbringing
our family our our parents our guidance
counselors our teachers our
we've just been conditioned to think
small because we're learning about life
from people who
also never thought big and so
because we are products of our
environment we have conditioned
ourselves to think the same way is it
that people in our environment and if
you're not happy with your environment
and your environment is not around
around big people who've done amazing
things or thinking big then you will
stay stock thinking small as well what I
love about Naveen Jane is that he thinks
big you know the first time I found this
content there were three people who
I get recommended all the time you
should do a top 10 on this person you
should do an Express on this person you
should profile this person and there
were three people who for the first time
upon first consumption of their content
really blew me away one was Denzel
Washington
uh if you have not seen Denzel
Washington you should go watch this top
10. his backup plan for his life was
being a minister and he is a fire
presenter I just kind of a lot of times
we do actors it's really hard to get
anything good out of the interviews that
they're doing but Denzel Washington is a
whole other animal so he really blew me
away the second was Priyanka Chopra uh
who had just amazing set of interviews
and super intelligent bright woman and
the third was Naveen Jane where I'd like
no idea who this person is you should do
Naveen Jane great go look him I was like
oh my gosh this guy's amazing I want
more Naveen Jane in my life I think
that's a great sign you know like when
you find people like that even if you've
never met them and up until this year I
had never met Naveen Jana The Good
Fortune I just recently have him on on
my channel to do an interview in a
collaboration but up until that point
I'd never met him before and
when you find the people who make you
think bigger who make you feel more
confident to make you feel more bold
you around them more
this is my solution right I am trying to
hang out even if it's just virtually
with the people who inspire me to want
to play a bigger game you know either
those three people I haven't met Denzel
Washington
yet I haven't met Priyanka Chopra yet uh
and up until you know this year I hadn't
met Naveen Jane yet but I can still be
inspired by them I can still learn from
them I can still look at their content
and it can still push me to become
better
and I think a lot of us stay stuck and
stay small because it's so
good to feel important
and we end up being the big fish in a
small pond if you're watching this video
you are probably the one that's pouring
into
everybody else you're probably the most
optimistic person in your circle you're
probably the one who cares the most
about the people around you you're
probably doing the most for the people
in your circle and you're the one people
come to and say Hey how do I X you know
how do I grow how do I get better how do
I you're the one that's advising and
helping and pushing other people maybe
pushing them too much that makes sense
maybe you're maybe you're pushing some
people too much but you're the most
optimistic most ambitious person in your
circle probably that's great in a sense
and that you can pour and give back and
help others along the way but who's
pushing you
you know if you don't have somebody
pushing you to be better to be stronger
to be greater to be more ambitious to
think bigger than you probably won't
like if you it's really uncomfortable to
think bigger
and if you don't have somebody inspiring
you pushing you helping you then you
probably stay stuck
and that's what we need to change and so
it's a message for you but it's a
message for me equally so and so step
one in doing that I think is just
changing the environment to be around
the people who do inspire you and
chances are most of the people who do
inspire you are not not people who have
you have direct access to and not people
who are taking on an intern you know
Warren Buffett's not taking on an intern
to go live with him for a year as far as
I know
so how do you do it well the easy way is
through content
I've learned so much and been inspired
so much by just amazing people through
the content on my own channel like I
make these videos for me because I need
them because I need to believe more in
myself and then I share that with you
and thankfully enough of you like it
that I can make it a business and hire a
team and continue to make even more
content because if it was just me then
it'd be a lot fewer videos coming up and
a lot less profiles and a lot less
content
so being around the people and when you
find people who really speak to you who
really get you going who like yes this
is exactly what I need then
be around them more subscribe to their
channels buy their books listen to their
podcasts be around them more if they're
speaking an event go to the event
because it'll push you to reach another
level
and this is why it's so great to have so
many people now I'm I'm passionate about
helping bring
new people onto the to platforms like
YouTube and getting their message out
there because some people
[Music]
will push you through things some people
will hug you through things everybody
has their own lens and you'll connect
with people in a different way so you
look at uh Eric Thomas so you look at a
Jocko willink or you look at uh Andy
frisella
who are going to be very in your face
cut right to the truth no BS no excuses
no wiggle room like get up and go chase
down your life you know it's a hard push
they may be yelling at you they're very
intense it's a hard push forward and
then there'll be other people like Oprah
like
um brene Brown like Dave Meltzer who
have a different approach it's a much
softer approach they'll hug you through
it you know some people will push you
and yell at you to get through it and
some people will hug you through it a
lot of times the message is exactly the
same you know Oprah's message is very
similar to Eric Thomas's message the
difference is the delivery
Oprah will hug you through it and Eric
will push you through it and it really
just depends on what you need there's no
right or wrong it's just what do you
need and when you find the people who
give you what you need just be around it
more be around that more because no
matter how much you watch one video
the impact will wear off right like
you're waking up tomorrow
the same person you were almost
yesterday maybe a half a percent better
but you could be you could watch this
video get all inspired be like yes all
right I'm gonna chase things down
amazing let's go and you have energy for
a few hours for the day but then you
wake up tomorrow and and that energy is
gone right has that happened to you that
energy suddenly is not there anymore you
don't feel as bold as courageous or
ambitious as you were yesterday why what
happened
it's not that there's nothing wrong with
you that's just normal
because you got an injection into your
environment that took you to another
level and then it it fell off
because there was no consistency in the
environment so you are what you
consistently do so whatever you want to
accomplish whoever you want to be to
consistently surround yourself with
people like that
because you're not getting enough in
your home environment your home your
environment now your life has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are it's allowed you to get to where you
are right now amazing and if that's
where all you want to be awesome
congratulations you've done it you've
you've hit the jackpot but if you want
more
then your current environment is not
designed to help you go and get more and
again I'm talking to myself just as much
as I'm talking to you like saying these
words out loud it's like what changes do
I need to make to my environment who do
I need to be hanging out with more
either in person or just through the
video content to make me want to
push more be more courageous save save
Bolder things and have bigger
aspirations and goals and dreams and and
take Boulder action towards
accomplishing them
right makes a big big difference and so
if you want to accomplish something if
it's business success or mindset success
then it was just thinking bigger then if
you love Naveen Jane be around Naveen
Jane more
watch all his interviews and then listen
to any podcasts that he does and I did
one on my main Channel we'll link that
up at the end of this video you can go
watch if you want if you want to improve
your health and fitness and you're tired
of you know being on an Oreo diet okay
you can make a choice and a decision
that I'm gonna I want to be this person
I want to be the person who works out I
want to be the person who takes care of
my body takes care of my health and
energy and
that's awesome as a decision but you
need the environment to support you and
so now if you're subscribing to health
channels if you're following people on
Instagram who are working out and take
care of their bodies it will make you
want to live a healthier life one of the
ones that I love watching is Tom bilyu
and his health Theory show where he's
interviewing experts around health and
every time I listen I was listen to one
this morning every time I listen watch
it makes me want to be a little bit
healthier
you know the more that you're around
that kind of stuff the more you will
take on the mindset similarly if you're
injecting poison like if you're around
negative people or you're consuming
negative content and that's most of the
news and most of media to be honest is
mostly negative if you're surrounded by
negativity constantly and you're you're
watching negative videos and reading
negative news constantly you will be a
lot more negative you'll be a lot more
scared you'll be a lot more scarcity
mindset you'll be a lot more afraid
you'll be a lot less positive and
ambitious because that's what you're
feeding into your mind so be very
careful about now designing and
Engineering your environment your
environment has happened to you
you know you've had some control over it
but it's it's mostly happened to you
and now you can with intent change it
to be more positive if you had to ask
yourself if I wanted to surround myself
with the most positive encouraging
inspiring
people who will make me more courageous
bold and ambitious
who would those people be what would
that environment look like
I didn't make a choice
change it
change who you subscribe to change what
you're listening and watching
unsubscribe from all the channels that
make you feel worse about yourself
change your physical environment what
what clothes are you wearing what do you
put on the wall around you what's your
background on your cell phone and on
your computer you start to change it and
when you change your environment
it'll Force the change in your habits in
your mindset and in your thinking you
have no idea what you're capable of you
have no idea you have no idea the person
you could be the things you could
accomplish the things you can do the
people you can serve you have no idea
that's why I don't like 10-year goals
10-year goals think about who you used
to be 10 years ago you know could that
person accurately with any with any
degree of certainty predict where you
could be right now now like if you're
growing and you're learning and you're
improving and you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of crew
you should go into right we're told we
should do all these things you're told
you're like who you know nobody ever
thought to ask us what we want for our
lives and you may not even know and
that's okay like you may know where you
want to go next but you may not
ultimately know the Final Destination
it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows like question
everything I wanna I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
playing small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and plans but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know if you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and this group of
super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals it's like
you you don't know what the real problem
is the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
um given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business and
people here have sold their businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them try to fit
into my box I'd rather fit into theirs
because in trying to understand how they
process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no that's
not going to work for me you know even
boom you gotta be I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh only time in
my life I've been sung by bee and it I
was on the floor and my my back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway maybe question everything except
bee stings how about that uh there's
been times when people have given me
advice and it made sense and it really
fit and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where you
were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I end up doing is making a
new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
following so when creating a new plan
then I have certainty in the plan again
and I'm fine and I'm rock and rolling
but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe it anymore and I'm rocking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be a downward spiral
like if I believe in the plan and the
plan is not working and I can't come
with a new plan then I don't know what
to do with my life and that would create
a downward spiral I've never gone
anywhere close to depression or suicide
but that would lead to some dark that
could lead to some dark places and so
the way that I come out of it is just
say great things will happen to me great
things happen to me they already they
always happen to me great things happen
to me and I'll figure this out and that
gives me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in anxiety
filled that I couldn't come with a new
plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing a
plan guy that's my ongoing challenge to
myself that's how I'm questioning it's
the willingness to question what you're
doing because what you're doing right
now has gotten you to where you're at
and if you're if you're happy with where
you're at cool but if you want more you
want to create more you want to serve
more you want to bring more you want to
help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change
and the change starts with not just
questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome did you
see my recent one-on-one with Tony
Robbins check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there quality
of your life has nothing to do with how
much money you have on me beautiful
children you have how many people love
you the quality of your life is where
you live emotionally this is the time to
retool it's a time for you to say
where's the world now where do I think
it's going and